I was in a piano class with Prince back
in junior high school and I remember at
the end of the school year they said hey
we're putting together like a band for a
musical who wants to play and we all
raised our hands and so they look at
Prince and they go Prince what do you
want to play and he said guitar and I
looked at Prince like guitar I thought
you played keyboards right and then they
said Jimmy what do you want to play and
I said I want to play drums and Prince
looked at me like drums we get into the
uh rehearsal room I'm sitting behind the
drums Prince walks in with a guitar he
plugs the guitar in and he rips off Note
fornote the guitar solo in make me smile
and everybody's Jaws were just on the
ground I knew what a great keyboard
player he was and of course later on I
found out what a great drummer he was
and everybody found out what a great
all-around musician he was but man he
just killed it
man